[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans diagonale tv
leçon spécial débutants avec ninon
maisuradze et bonjour ni non oui jours
alors aujourd'hui dans cette leçon nous
allons voir les déplacements élémentaire
de certaines pièces notamment en fait de
trois pièces qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui qui sont la tour le fou et
la dame lesdain alors ce sont trois
pièces important en terme aux échecs
évident on compte toutes les pièces
publiées sont importantes et c'est pas
par hasard qu'on a choisi tour fou et
dames
non on va le voir on va voir pourquoi
pourquoi donc faut bien se rappeler ces
trois pièces en ondes au petit cousinage
on va voir tout ça avec nos exemples du
jour pour savoir comment ces pièces se
déplace aux échecs en commençant par le
tour voila voila vous voyez où
maintenant la position donc ici on a
alors il faut toujours des rois sur un
échiquier puisque il peut pas y avoir de
position sont les rois puisque les rois
est ce qu'elle est les rois nenê ces
captures pas aussi jeune tueur pas
puisque c'est la pièce fondamentale
quand le roi a capturé ces la fin de la
partie
alors ici nous avons donc une tour
blanche
il n'y a aucune autre pièce que ça nous
permettra de mieux voir le déplacement
alors comment se déplacent cette tour
donc les tours se déplace sur les
rangées et les colons alors suivront jeu
nous a expliqué premier recours donc
c'est à dire verticalement ou
horizontalement donc ici comme ça voilà
pour vous que vous comprenez mieux
alors est-ce que ça peut aller en
arrière aussi oui bien sûr donc plupart
des pièces au dossier coin aussi à
l'arrière des roues arrière racontait
comme vous voulez d'ici 6 et aux blancs
de jouer la tour peut aller sur toutes
les cases qui sont marqués en verre par
exemple moi je dire sur la case b4 ici
par exemple venir sur cette case ici qui
est la case e 6
oui ou par exemple sur la case h4
d'employabilité pour nos remarques et on
est pas limité par rapport à distance si
la voix est libre on voulait aller
jusqu'à doubler au maximum par exemple
ici oui voilà donc la tohu est allé
jusqu ici donc il sera différent retenir
par leurs déplacements des pieds si
c'est la différence il ya les pièces de
placer des bornes en général c'est à
dire aux échecs déjà il faut connaître
et on ne peut pas sauter sur une autre
pièce c'est à dire dessus on peut pas
sauter par dessus
il est catholique il peut le faire mais
ça on a expliqué plus tard donc on va
vous montrer tout à l'heure une position
d'exemples où on nous montrait comment
une piste pc faire bloquer affectivement
voilà juste à me dire comment une
capture les pieds sautés chic on dit
pour vous expliquer c'est ça s'applique
à tous les pièces donc par différemment
des dom on a pas trop parlé comparé à
tous les lieux mais comme vous savez
adama sow a sauté sur une pièce on va
capturer cette pièce c'est cette manière
on saute par-dessus aux dames effectuer
des chéquiers s'il y est présente crise
que vous pouvez prendre où vous allez
retirer cette piéce et vous avez placé
autre pièce sur le même endroit
voilà on verra ça tout à l'heure dans
l'exemple a donc passons de médecins pas
d'être sur le fou si vous avez rétabli
le meneur des ailes à tour voilà pour la
tour c veille c'est facile en trouvant
le fou alors maintenant le fou lui il se
trimballe comment henninot donc sur les
diagonales
alors donc il peut aller tour toutes ces
cases ici diagonale voilà toutes ces
cases ici donc par exemple on va montrer
des exemples de coups par exemple ce fou
peut très bien aller sur la case h suite
ici il peut aller aussi sur la casse
géant où il peut choisir s'est déplacé
avec uniquement sur une seule case par
exemple pourquoi ben sur la case ici
voilà cette case ici donc vous voyez
n'importe où sur le b / diagonale de
même couleur ou vous n'allez pas c'est
si vous êtes placé sur le gaz noir vous
allez continuez vous dirigez sur les
cases noires avec le fou donc à savoir
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué 2 si vous
vous rappelez de la première cour
le placement des pièces quand on regarde
et vous allez découvrir il ya deux
couleurs de fou sur donc si un éléphant
ou celui des fuites donc là dans cette
position on a en fou qui est placé sur
le t4
vous voyez les notations qui est les
cases noires mais il peut avoir une
foule blanc ou blanc et ça change rien
ça il va se diriger sur le diagonal
blanc cette fois surtout qu'il ya deux
fous au départ effectivement il ya le
fou qui est sur la cas c'est un
si vous vous rappelez le placement des
pièces et le fou qui se trouve au départ
sur la case f1 ici le roi a pris la
place mais au départ de la partie il y
avait un fou ici il a disparu a sans
doute été mangé et bien voyez que celui
ci aurait bougé sur les cases blanches
alors que celui ci mais il était
forcément sur cases noires et ils se
retrouvent ici au centre et il a bougé
sur cases noires on nous invite à aller
voir notre premier recours pour réviser
et le placement la pièce tout à fait
alors on a vu la tour maintenant la vue
le fou donc on a vu la tour se déranger
les colonnes le fou c'est les diagonales
pour l'instant mystérieux maintenant la
dame qui est un peu plus technique
oui puisque la dame elle l est encore
plus puissante que les deux pièces la
dame c'est la pièce la plus puissante
aux échecs à retenir ça donc une pièce
très précieuse la dame ses pratiquants
est la combinaison de fou et or voilà
fouet tour donc ça veut dire que la dame
se déplace à la fois comme le fou comme
le fou donc sur les diagonales et à la
fois comme la tour sur les vertes est à
la fois comme la tour donc sur ollon et
rangés sur les colonnes et les ranger
regardez toutes les cases ont regardé
oui la puissance et d'armes combien
quand il peut prendre en même temps il
peut prendre que c'est une pièce
vraiment qu'ils contrôlent tôt donc
voilà alors donc exemple de coûts pour
pour les blancs ici la dame peut très
bien venir sur la case ici j'ai 5
elle peut très bien aussi venir sur la
case b 3 arrêts toutes les possibilités
qui sont offertes par la dame c'est tout
à fait une pièce magnifique qui peut
aller un peu où on veut aller toutes ces
possibilités voilà donc à la fois c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis le déplacement
effectivement de ces trois pièces dans
cette même émission me normand parce que
la dame combine
la puissance du fou à la fois et de la
tour en même temps et donc là une très
très grande puissance un très grand
rayonnement sur l'échiquier comme vous
pouvez le constater ici
alors quoi maintenant on va voir en innu
un exemple qui va nous permettre de
synthétiser l'ensemble de ces mouvements
de pièces prêtées cela vous paraît ainsi
vos difficile complexe de vue mais vous
allez voir vous allez vite et facilement
alors on y va tac ici voilà voilà une
position typiques de d'échec si on a
joué donc il ya à la fois dame tour est
fou on a mis aussi des pions c'est pas
le sujet de la lotion d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est pour montrer certaines
possibilités donc déjà on vous rappelle
encore une fois donc sur comment c'est
que les pièces peut-être pour montrer
donc aux échecs vous ne pouvez pas comme
on disait sauter ce verrou propre
reprise on peut pas sauter sur ses
propres pièces donc ça veut dire ce que
tu nous dit nino que ce fou ne peut pas
venir sur la case à 4 il peut pas parce
qu'il ya le pion ici ce pion b3 qui le
bloque donc il ne peut pas venir sur
cette case voilà quatre donc on va la
marquer en rouge
oui ce qui peut pas maintenant dessus
alors est ce qui pourrait venir à la
place du pion b3 non plus alors pourquoi
parce que les pièces ne peut pas prendre
au pied cela va prendre en même temps
donc une seule case et vous ne peut pas
non plus place et vous voyez sur votre
propre
c'est pourquoi prend ça revient c'est un
peu comme la guerre sale ou trahison on
peut pas être entre guillemets tuer ses
propres soeurs et dell quoi ça oui aux
échecs ça n'arrive à c'est plus chic la
règle est totalement
donc vous ne pouvez pas vous pourrez
capturer vos propres pièces ça
n'existait pas encore uniquement les
pieds cet adversaire donc on peut pas
non seulement avec le fonds peut pas
évidemment venir sur un câble et 3
passes qui est un pion de son propre
camp et on peut évidemment pas passer
par dessus non plus on peut parier que
s'il pouvait pas pressé douter sur une
selle casse donc alors par contre on va
pouvoir venir sur la case bien on va
pouvoir venir sur la case d1 et toutes
ces cases là alors maintenant il ya la
tour ici j'ai 6 ans lorsque l'âge est le
droit d'aller sur la casse g6 et donc la
scène autour d'adversaires j'ai droit au
vol oui là où vous est donc prendre
capturer les pieds de l'adversaire donc
là je prends la tour donc ça c'est une
ultime commande vous disais vous pouvez
capturer donc les pieds adverses et
comment vous n'allez pas aller en
capturant sur eux par exemple 7 mai sur
g6 directement donc c'est tout va
disparaître
on va voir si la tour et disparaît ça
veut dire quoi vous allez retirer sont
tout simplement d'échiquier et m à côté
voilà donc là on a pris et vous vous
installez sur la place et ses tours
voilà donc là on a pris la toile par
contre est ce qu'on a le droit d'aller
sur la case h7 nos parce qu'elle est
tour plus que toujours on peut va sauter
non plus les pieds stade earth voilà
donc on peut pas sauter les pièces que
ce soit ses propres pièces où les pieds
sales mais on ne peut pas sauter par
dessus donc la cage à sète n'est pas
disponible pour le fou par contre on
peut prendre la tour et donc remplacer
simplement la tour par son propre fous
et voilà comment on prend les pièces aux
échecs comme ça c'était pour le fou il
ya une seule pièce qui veulent s'opposer
chic et ça on va voir plus tard c'est le
cavalier comme le cheval qui souhaitent
mais pour l'instant donc les
déplacements des trois pièces qu'on
vient d'apprendre la dame la tour le fou
et ces pièces là il peut pas il veut
jamais sauter ni soeur propre prix et
signé cet adversaire
alors prenons maintenant l'exemple de la
tour de la tour blanche
alors comme on a vu la tour peuvent se
déplacer sur les sur les rangées alors
elle peut aller donc du coup sûr c'est
toutes ces cases là que je marque
converse elle peut aller aussi sur ces
deux quasi si elle ne peut pas aller par
contre par là la question et script est
allé sur le plateau roy nos vies la
science et à sa propre ville
on peut aller là par contre on peut
aller là on peut aller en f4 f5 pardon
en f 6 est-ce qu'on peut aller en f 7
oui là aussi c'est ce qu'on vient de
capturer à une pièce adversaires donc
dans ce cas là on prendrait le pion ici
et on remplace le pion tout simplement
par la toux et voilà ça c'est possible
et est ce qu'on a le droit d'aller sur
la case f8 respecta devra répondre
réfléchissez à ce niveau mais nous la
réponse et nous voilà donc on peut pas
puisqu'on peut pas sauter par dessus le
pion donc voila voila pour la tour
toutes les possibilités qu'elle a
regardé comme les blocs est à la fois
ici par le roi ou là elle peut pas du
tout y aller ici elle peut aller
jusqu'aux pions puisqu'elle peut prendre
le pion mais elle ne peut pas aller sur
la case et suite puisque il faudrait
passer par dessus le pion et ça c'est
totalement interdit alors reste la dame
ici donc peut-être on vous laisse en
tutti pour réfléchir pendant qu'on
allait les cases colorées
est ce que cette dame est peut être
capturée par exemple peut-être vous
pouvez déjà commencer à réfléchir par
vous même c'est un peu de capturer par
l'adversaire tu veux dire oui par
exemple et la question risque et cédant
fait d'être capturé est-ce que c'est à
attaquer voilà l'horizon voilà alors
bien alors on montrait maintenant on
voit qu'ici la dame noire ici oui
pourrait se déplacer comme un fou et
prendre la dame blanche
bon c'est aux blancs de joueurs donc on
peut pas le voir mais imaginons que les
blancs jouent un coup c'est tout simple
on va jouer un coup de tous voilà
et puis maintenant les noirs pourrait
jouer dame ici bessette prend la dame
ici en d5
donc on est tout simplement la voilà
dans m'apprendre la dame ils sont à
retirer donc la dame des chéquiers et
l'autre dans à prendre sa place alors on
va montrer pour la dame noire par
exemple puisque
on verse un peu les couleurs toutes les
cases où elle peut aller elle peut aller
aussi sur la casse et 6 elle peut aller
sur la casse s'est vite puisqu'elle se
déplace comme un fou elle peut aller sur
gaza ville alors elle peut pas aller sur
la case et les huit cadres rooney sur
ces 7
bien sûr on peut pas aller sur ces 7 non
plus et du coup je peux pas aller non
plus sur ces cases 1 puisque ce faudrait
que je passe par dessus de vous
messieurs je peux aller ici je peux
aller sur la classe a6
je peux aller sur ces cases ici et je
peux aussi prendre le pion b3 donc nous
c'est possible d'aller en b3 je peux
jouer le coup mais on pourrait pas jouer
aller jusqu'aux bedo par exane prend b3
mais je peux pas aller effectivement sur
la case des deux puisqu'il faudrait je
passe par dessus le pion lee la case
bien hong lei a des liens fermé donc là
on voit bien les possibilités pour se
voyait déjà une dame qui a entouré de
pièces à moins de puissance comme on l'a
vu tout à l'heure une pierre une dame
qui est au centre de l'échiquier tout
comme tout à l'heure oui aucune pièce
elle a un rayonnement terrible alors que
là tout de suite bien et moins de 15
disponibles donc maintenant si vous
connaissez déjà de placement des pieds
c'est un petit peu connaissent et
comment ces deux places la dame le fou
la tour vous voyez que dans la position
de départ
les pions qui sont placés justement les
pieds ça les dérange ans à l'aise on
laisse passer pour ça vous allez voir
plus tard qu'est le plus souvent on va
commencer le premier co par le pion par
le pion bull pour les laisser ces
diagonales pour les laisser ces écolos
donc je crois qu'on a on a vu dans cette
dans cette émission important donc le
déplacement de ces trois pièces
importantes que sont le fou la tour et
la dame qui combine les deux donc
éliminé doc y ait une paix sans pièce le
plus puissante des chèques
gardez bien autre dame ne s'agit pas
contre vous expliquer plus tard ainsi
que la valeur des pièces mais déjà vous
pouvez savoir que la danse est la plus
puissante tout à fait la dame la plus
puissante
donc voilà c'est fini pour cette pour
cette courte leçon sur le déplacement de
ces trois pièces fondamentales à
connaître fou tour et dames merci ni
nous pour cette leçon rien
au revoir et on vous retrouvez donc pour
la suite pour apprendre déplacer le
cavalier le pion bon alors exactement
merci au revoir roy
[Musique]